Speaker 1: This is really, really great stuff
we're going to look at now. Remember Trump's legal
adviser, John Eastman? He's the lawyer who wrote
the infamous KU memo with various ideas as to how
maybe Donald Trump would be able to steal
the 2020 election? Lauren Windsor, our friend
from the undercurrent, has done it again and has
gotten undercover. VIDEO Speaking to John Eastman,
essentially just bragging about the entire memo,
his role and everything. Let's take. Let's just
go right into it. We've got video. We've got
audio. The video is subtitled. Let's just jump
right in and see, this is amazing stuff.
Speaker 2: We're huge Trump supporters.
Speaker 1: We were shocked by the way. This
is Lauren pretending to be a Trump supporter.
She's been doing this now for months, and
she gets people to put down their guard and
say really horrible and damning things.
Speaker 2: January six Oh yeah,
we saw your speech.
Speaker 3: I incite
you to go down to the Capitol and riot.
Speaker 2: You actually incited as they become
supporters of Claremont. Oh, good. Very good. Very
good. You know, the work that you're doing is so
critical to saving our democracy, and it's like
Speaker 1: we couldn't be so good at blowing
smoke up people's asses. It's so
funny. I support your work after that.
Okay. Well, thank you very much and very
Speaker 3: kind of you. So thank you.
You're really doing the Lord's work, right?
You know, God, you heard me say it. My
old professor said. If you're not catching
incoming flak, you're not over the target.
Unidentified: My God, I must be directly over
it because I don't think there's anybody that's
as much incoming flack,
Speaker 3: maybe,
than other than Trump himself that I have
Speaker 1: the biggest victim, my bottom part.
But I
Speaker 2: read
your memo and I thought it was solid in
Unidentified: all of its legal arguments.
I just I was floored that.
Then Mike Pence didn't do anything, I mean, why?
Speaker 1: So I understand what she's doing,
she's she's continuing to blow smoke, you know,
and saying that memo with like your six or eight
ways to steal the election, I
thought it was totally solid.
And how dare Mike Pence not actually go forward?
Unidentified: Did he act on it because you
gave him the legal reasoning to do
that? I know. I know. No. And now
Speaker 3: in a piece in
The Atlantic two days ago,
Unidentified: they're already anticipating
Trump winning in 2020 for. And they're
using my arguments from
Speaker 3: that memo
that they all said had no credibility
Speaker 2: to argue that Kamala Harris
can block the aisle.
Unidentified:
I mean, it's like, you know, it's
like, I mean, come on, basically
Speaker 2: everyone's going
to say you're being driven,
right? Yeah, exactly. Exactly. Except they're not
Speaker 1: saying that, right? So first of all,
the idea that maybe the memo was sort of like
in jest or whatever, he seems to really believe
that that was a way to steal the election.
Speaker 2: But that's what they mean. Yeah,
exactly. Like all your legal reasoning is
totally valid. Yeah, yeah. There's no question,
but maybe like, you know,
someone in a supporter like, why
Unidentified: do you think that Mike Pence
didn't do it? Well, because Mike Pence is an
establishment guy at the end of the day.
Speaker 1: How about that, huh? Trump's
legal adviser, who came up with a way to steal
the election, saying the reason Pence didn't
do it. Pence's establishment pence Pence's
too establishment to really do what needed
to be done at
Speaker 3:
all of the establishment Republicans in. But
into this very, very opaque view that Trump was
Unidentified: just throwing the Republican
Party and what Trump is doing is destroying
the inside the Beltway Republican Party and
reviving the Republican Party in the hinterland
right where they are considered to the, you know,
the horrible flyover country. And there's an
Speaker 3: uprising that Trump got ahead of.
He didn't create the movement. The movement was
there. And he saw it and got ahead of it.
Unidentified: But no, they can't tolerate
that because they all they
all have a nice, cushy living.
Speaker 1: This guy is a true believer
of this idea that Trump was this
big threat to the establishment, and he was
coming in and doing this and doing that. And
that's why Mike Pence and others didn't didn't
help Trump take the election that if there is ever
a true believer, it's this guy. We have another
clip here, and it's it's just as crazy. Let's
continue watching. Do you think it's like
Unidentified: something down like? He said
he was coming down low down in the capital,
Speaker 1: so understand the question here is
if Trump himself did march to the Capitol like
he said he was going to. Would that have maybe
succeeded in stopping the count?
Speaker 3: Yeah, I don't.
Unidentified: Yeah, I don't know. Because because.
Give me a break, you know, the Windows stuff had
already started before his. And if he
Speaker 3: got if he got down there,
then all of that
Speaker 1: would have been blamed on him. I like
how he minimizes the insurrectionists coup as the
breaking of the windows. There was a little more
going on than breaking windows. There's no blaming
Speaker 3: them, but they would have had more
faith in. So, you know, even planning on
coming down, though. Yeah, I know, I know,
I know. So yeah, look, the whole thing was
Unidentified: a setup and it was a setup.
John Sullivan and Chief A
Speaker 3: Guy got paid
sixty thousand bucks by CNN to break in and get
Speaker 1: video of violence. All right. This is
a fact. So again, this got this is how dangerous
these people are. We didn't necessarily know with
this Eastman character, is this a true believer?
Or did he get paid to write a memo like, OK, yeah,
here is like a hypothetical, very hypothetical
this. Nobody's really going to pay attention
to this. No one's going to believe this. This
wouldn't even really work. I don't know. I'll
just write it for you because I'm getting paid.
No, no, no, no. This undercover video seems to
be making clear this guy is a true believer.
He believes the Antifa conspiracy theories.
He believes it was actually legally viable to
steal the election the way he outlined in the.
It's incredible. They're all keywords.
Speaker 3: The Proud Boys had not just kind of
wallflowers sitting on the side and
Unidentified: you were going to.
But people instigating within the
associated. FBI plants, these were
Speaker 3: it was a setup.
Speaker 1: So the riots were antifa and the FBI.
Speaker 3: And you know, unfortunately, our guys
walk into. So he would have gone down there if it
hadn't been for the violence. Yeah, like he came,
Unidentified: he decided not to go because he more
engaging in violence and breaking
stuff. Yeah. He didn't want that,
right? No. And he immediately tweeted out
Speaker 3: what he said on his speech. Go down
there peacefully and patriotically,
you know, let your voice be
Speaker 1: heard, right? That's what actually
what Trump did was even hours after there had been
violent riots for hours. Trump reluctantly did
a video where he says it's time to go home. But
he mentioned, We love you and you're completely
justified in being here. I know why you're here.
It was stolen, etc. But it's time to go home.
After just hours of pressure of people saying,
Trump, sir. You got it. You got to say something.
You've got to get these people home. There's a
third part to this interview, which as of this
moment that we're recording today's show, Lauren
Windsor has not yet released, but I encourage you
to take a look at it when it is incredible stuff.
And we'll have more on this on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show